When we read the last and final
revelation of the glorious Quran, when I
say this life is a test for the
hereafter,
what are the guidelines of this test? If
you read surah al assur chapter number
103, it is called as Rah nijad the path
to salvation, the path to ja.
It says in surah al assur chapter number
103 verse number 1 to3
by the token of time Allah is taking the
oath of time
verily man is in a state of loss
except those who have faith
those who have righteous deed
those who invite people to truth do dawa
those who invite people to patience and
perseverance. So according to surah al
assur man is in kasara every human being
will go to hell except
those who have these four criteria.
Number one im
number
righteous deed number one faith number
two righteous deed number three
inviting people to truth doing dawa
inviting people to patience and
perseverance. If any one of these four
criteria is missing, you shall not enter
Jenna. You may be a very good Muslim.
You may be praying five times a day. You
may be fasting in the month of Ramadan.
You may have gone for Hajj. You may have
the mark on your forehead. But if you
don't do dawa according to surah assur,
you shall not enter Jenna. If Allah
wants to forgive you and put you in
Jenna, that's Allah's prerogative. But
under normal circumstances, all four are
equally important. Not only dawa im
righteous deed
inviting people to truth and inviting
people to patience and pursue all four
are equally important according to Imam
Shafi may Allah have mercy on him. He
said that if surah al assur alone was
revealed for humanity it would have been
sufficient for guidance. Imagine the
great Imm if surah al Assur was revealed
alone
not the full Quran only surah alas three
verses it is the second shortest surah
in the Quran if this was revealed alone
it would have been sufficient for haya
for guidance for humanity there was a
person a Jewish beggar at the time of
half his kalani and we know from the
books of history that half the scalani
he was a judge
and he was quite affluent and rich. So
this poor Jewish man goes and asks him
that I heard that a prophet said that
this dunya this world
for the believers is a prison and for
the unbelievers it is paradise. How can
you justify I am a beggar my clothes are
torn you are such a rich man you are a
Muslim I am a non-Muslim how can this
world be a paradise for me and a prison
for you
scalani he replied
and this hadith that the Jewish beggar
quoted is from say Muslim volume number
seven had number 7417
and Kalani
may Allah have mercy on him he said that
the Muslim knows that in the next life
he's going to get Jenna and if he knows
what Jenna is in this world even if
you're the richest man this life is like
prison compared to the next life even if
you're the richest man even if you're
the king if you know what is awaiting
you for Jenna
this world is nothing not even 01%
compared to Akara
That's the reason those who truly know
Islam,
what they want, they want to go to Jenna
fast. They're not afraid of death. They
aren't afraid of death. Why?
If a human being is on the straight path
of Saratust of Sural Assar, if he dies,
he goes to Jenna. So who would not like
to hasten to die? We cannot kill
ourselves. It's haram. Suicide is haram.
But of course, in the way of Allah, if
you're on the hak, you're not afraid.
You aren't afraid of anyone. If you're
on the hak, a true Muslim, if he's on
the he's not afraid of death because if
he dies, he goes to paradise. Even if
he's the richest man in the world, even
if he's 10 times richer than Bill Gates,
Elon Musk, and Jeff Bos all